autonomous cars are coming to the valley
yeah new road broke ground on its new
location in north las vegas promises
more than a billion dollar economic
boost for the area christian kosris
joining us live in studio and you were
there during a ceremony christian this
morning so how soon can we expect to see
this technology around town well brian
denise according to neuro the company is
expected to be in operation in a year
now this is even bigger news for a craig
road corridor right there which is
expected to see a big boost in business
you're getting a glimpse of the first
self-driving vehicle to operate in north
las vegas
mayor john lee welcomed tech company
nero to the city as they get ready to
build their manufacturing facility on
this 10-acre lot on craig and bruce
street the expected economic impact is
expected to be about 2.2 billion dollars
over the next 10 years we expect that to
produce about 200 jobs in the area and
also a testing facility at the las vegas
motor speedway where we're going to
really
test our vehicles before we deploy them
on the roads the company plans on
partnering with schools to grow their
staff the project is one of several
that's booming along this popular
corridor of the city this will fit right
in with with this mayor and this
council's vision as to bring in more
manufacturing jobs high paying
sustainable jobs restaurants amenities
residential communities so that we have
just a variety for this diverse
workforce that we're going to be
bringing forth we need that this soul
food restaurant has been in business for
over 10 years and has been a part of the
growth in the neighborhood nero's
arrival according to this business owner
will mean more foot traffic and hiring
more staff i think it would be awesome i
think would help a lot of the business a
lot of the
people that still don't want to come out
during the pandemic you can stay at home
order your pizza and you're not out on
the roads you're not running errands
you're not running into traffic
pretty cool stuff there all right nero
has partnered with kroger's dominoes and
fedex mayor lee says he hopes this
project will attract similar companies
to north las vegas christian gaza is
live local now